[Music]
is that not the most awesome thing you
have ever seen
that is really wonderful it feels like a
real competition doesn't I am I am in
fact I am Flip Phillips I am one of your
MCS and welcome to the third annual of
wolfram live coding championship one
I'll announce or introduce real quickly
the judges so we've got Bob Mac bar over
here Danny Finn fresh from some food
poisoning but doing better got Roman
Mader we've got and the you know
basically the person singularly
responsible for all of this who is too
embarrassed to take all the credit but
should anyway Jesse Friedman everybody
give him just a stand up Jesse
there you go you were standing I'm sorry
[Laughter]
and I'm going to introduce my co-host
for the evening reigning champion
undefeated because he's R in retirement
it's a new level anyway chip Hearst
everybody I think your honor
that's right flip I'm just an athlete
who's retired to the announcer's booth
so folks for those of you at home who
don't know what this is this is a live
coding championship so we have a bunch
of competitors out here who will be
given a bunch of questions to code
whoever's the fastest will get more
points and what's interesting is we
don't grade on them getting the right
answer they also have to provide the
code and we run it and check and make
sure it's generating the right answer so
it's a completely automated process some
laughter over there yeah I know we're
gonna catch you and we have three humans
to take the place of the AI that is
secretly doing all of the
but before we begin I think I want to
hear a word from the original live coder
Stephen Wolfram let's hear for Stephen
thanks you know I've been doing a lot of
live coding stuff I think I first did
live coding in 1980 so I've been doing
it a while it's really a lot of fun I
particularly like doing it in front of
audiences and things I however am very
much a non-competitive kind of guy so I
it's true it's some so so I'm not
somebody to compete in this kind of
thing but I think it's really fun and
maybe I maybe I will end up competing
all right well anyway it's what some
what's great here is with our whole
Wolfram language technology stack it's
some you can make non-trivial code in a
few lines you can really make things
happen quickly it's fun to do it's fun
to watch hope everybody has fun so back
to chip here all right thanks for those
words Steven Thanks
all right so I think it's about time we
get started yeah flip I think we're
ready
how's the crowd what about the crowd the
crowd ready my ants are we ready all
right competitors let's get the
competitors you guys pumped you ready
all right Bob unleash the first question
[Music]
find the ten people with the most
Wolfram language symbols named after
them and return the most common country
of birth among them as a country entity
good luck competitors ok so so we I
believe the first question was just sent
out yes symbol epidemic every news we
heard it so let's take a look at what
our our competitors are are doing the
first one here yeah yeah so I switched
over to to one of the to one of the
screens that we have and for people
right now okay there we go
so right now we're looking at the left
one there I'm not sure that that person
is there they're using Wolfram language
symbol I think that's the that's the
right approach it's an entity type you
know their approach to be Wolfram
language data yeah yes Wolfram language
there as well so it's an entity type
within the Wolfram knowledge base that
contains data about symbols in the
Wolfram language oh that's good okay hey
this looks like they've gotten that the
the eponymous people property which gets
for a for a given symbol we hope it's
named I remember people let's switch
over to to another person here let's see
yeah that's that screen so human system
yes they product the documentation page
for Wolfram language data in the back
which is although it looks like they're
using entity value it's just two ways to
do the same thing really so they're
using the eponymous people property as
well they've also gotten gotten on that
this competitor has gone to the language
data also or has gone I'm sorry yeah
this one sorry so yes this this
competitor yeah they're on the
documentation page for a Wolfram
language data and they found on the
example the exact same example always
that way Wow
always look for the example
so that's the that's the advantage of
using the documentation not only will it
tell you how to use the function but
maybe the person who wrote this question
stole from the documentation of this I
don't know and this person over here on
the fourth monitor fiddling and battling
they're almost trying to reverse
engineer the problem yeah so they're
trying to using the person entity type
which is a giant we see it's downloading
about 480,000 of people yeah and hey
they've almost downloaded them all who
knows hey it's interesting and
interesting stuff from that as well
so over to Coby right yeah they found
the place of birth property which is a
property of the person entity antitype
and they're in the place of birth is a
is I think I think the place of birth
can be multiple ending I know it looks
like they got it they just need to clean
it up and submit you're right yeah I
think they're getting the country of I
guess place of birth is a city and
they're getting the country associated
with that city so I think they're very
close alright so I think I'm gonna go
out and not get ready to announce to the
audience that we have our first yeah
let's let's just wait until until we
still get here from from from the judges
just to make sure I'm one of you wanna
win so ok here I'm gonna smooth it so
fine
so I'm switching over here actually to
the - to the secret judges feed my
personal favorite right so we can see
this is the result from the automatic
grading system it looks like we got we
got that I think that might have been
that might be the person we were just
looking at on the screen
yes but they I don't think they read the
quick oh oh oh we've got a correct
answer from from Gurley that is a
correct solution from from girly so
girly does seem to be our first so here
I think they didn't read the question
quite close enough because it's asking
okay so they were close they yeah just
take the comments yes
carefully gone back to reread the
question yes a classic classic strategy
strategy okay so that's interesting look
at that even Wolfram is up there with
with the the most eponymous are the
people with the most eponymous symbols
alright folks we have one correct answer
so far Oh two correct answers so
remember once the third correct answer
is submitted we will start the
one-minute timer it's very and everyone
else has one more minute to try to
submit a correct answer that's right
okay we have three correct so the second
that starts counting down you have one
minute to try to submit more for it to
recognize my face all right one minute
one minute
Hado job okay all right good oh yes oh
that's good we were watching over there
and commenting that the going back to
read the question a fine strategy for
all all students I'm three seconds left
exact solution to this I think by the
way the music tonight by value Wolfram
tone yes Wolfram tones for every every
symbol in the language let's hear from
Wolfram times ten seconds and then make
sure and tip your whites that's
interesting they're using four three two
one alright gentlemen and that's the end
of question one of question one good job
everybody so we'll give the judges a few
minutes to tally up the the goodness so
yeah let's go let's go over talk real
quick to John because he did because we
were we were commenting with you on the
live stream
so what tell us again you you were close
yeah you handle but the communist
country but I didn't read the questions
so I hate chatting and I realized I had
communist to the end of the code yeah
and once you did that you were in right
so good good job anybody else oh they're
still judging lots of judging going on
up deliberating yes now that now we just
go over and and hang out with the judges
got some people doing the wave back
there
Wow now now is that a standing wave
physicists now have to ask wave
questions because they're standing I got
you yeah okay I just want to make sure
so we're just waiting on the judges no
pressure no pressure just think about
what it takes to be a judge here all
right the scoreboard has been updated
there we go
so it looks like we got girly with for
first place
congratulations heart whoopee Oh
[Applause]
all right yes we got degenerate
degenerate artists yes the anonymous
degenerate artist and finally with one
point Jose yeah all right so Jerry Lee
Congrats you want to tell us real just
real quick kind of what you did I looked
at the documentation that's an excellent
answer she looked at the documentation
perhaps perhaps perhaps the best
solution all right that's great so with
one question one question down girly
Wolfie degenerate artist in Jose come on
the rest of you get your $20 gift
certificate for getting one point you
have we work hard on the next one
[Music]
all right it's time for question number
two take a chip all right it's rule 30
edge components evolve rule 34 2,000
steps starting from a single one
centered on the background of zeros use
the evolution as input to morphological
components with corner neighbors set to
false and find the number of distinct
components on the diagonal on the
rightmost diagonal of the automaton how
many distinct components are on the
rightmost diagonal of the otamatone your
answer will be a simple integer thank
you we had a big cluster over here when
working together
I switched us to one of our one of the
screens they seem to be using the the
using the cellular automaton function to
evolve the rule 37 ton for 2,000 steps
they've got that and they've wrapped it
in image cellular automaton returns a
matrix a two-dimensional binary matrix
and they're converting it to a Wolfram
language symbolic image object and then
they're calling morphological components
corner neighbors to false that's there
they're on the right track definitely
absolutely so just left is is finding
the components that border the right
edge yes so and that's good that's it
there's a nice kind of logical stopping
point to chunk this into these these
pieces right and I am digging the
wulfing tones I'm not gonna lie so
colorize the output of morphological
components is the same matrix but
instead of binary they're they're
integer values where one represents a
certain component so all they're all the
ones
are together and so it would be one one
of one of those many colors and in there
and then two would be another component
so it's a matrix of integers instead of
just a matrix of zeros and ones and now
they're looking at the raw data to get a
sense that's is yeah what the first
pixel so they were trying to figure out
what the first component is because they
would think it would be the middle of
that yeah so what just to be clear to to
help understand the question what
they're trying to do if you saw that
that color eyes hopefully they'll scroll
back to it what they're trying to do is
count how many distinct colors are on
the right edge since it's a triangle or
on the right edge of that that thing so
there may be more colors it looks like
yeah there we go
and here we can switch to another
competitor who's also on the same track
so yeah there may be oh there looks like
they made a mistake and have a special
way if that's the so again remember for
this question it's not the number of
components in the image it's the number
of components that touch the rightmost
diagonal there's a difference from the
matrix right so wonder what wonder what
function they might use to do that yeah
so here we're on our third contestant
I'm just taking a look there it looks
like they're a little behind the rest
but they're on this they're on the right
track I believe not sure what's up with
that in cellular automaton and join
table looks like they're using a unusual
way to form the the range specification
I get or the initial conditional
condition for them cellular automaton
and so they're yeah they're creating the
initial conditions array of a thousand
manually while you there is actually a
syntax that the other contestants have
used we can we can see here where they
have the the that second argument of
cellular automaton where it's bracket
bracket 1 close bracket 0 so it just
means a single one on an infinite
background
it's somewhat more efficient or cleaner
way of describing those initial
revisions but either way what yes
absolutely
and it's a completely valid so oh I
think we have our I I believe an answer
that we're seeing here is is correct on
on competitor one yes so our judges are
saying that a few people are getting
close yeah I know I think yeah it's a
bit tricky because of the way how this
system works
oh yeah so the way this special
competition system works is that so
letters have to select all of the cells
that they so don't forget you have to
submit see because I gotta miss one cell
we do have one correct that session so
to correct just heard from the judges we
have to correct common solutions that
came through so yeah I do see one in
this list I'm not sure what the second
one is it might have been that the
autograder made a mistake yes and the
judges over I did it ungraded something
is as yeah I see yeah that's what it
submitted the whole thing yes so okay
yeah I'm just looking at I suppose I can
put up the no reason I can't put up the
goes right the list here and I did see
this one correct solution from early but
then several others that have do have
the same or one other that has the same
result I suspect that this is the this
is the autograder result and I suspect
the judges autograder made it made of
all right we have three correct
submissions so once flip gets the timer
going we have one minute starting now
everyone any concentration of cons are
yourself interesting I would have
thought read do and do things I I'm not
sure what what name corresponds to which
of these monitors that I have in front
of me 17 seconds everybody seven seconds
okay three two one all right round of
applause uh that was kind of tricky that
was kind of a tricky question so let's
wait for the judges to update potential
solutions will deliberate a little
longer
make sure everything's correct put up
the correct solution submitted by the
first person and then we'll tally up the
points yeah you know just based on the
demeanor of people in here during the
questions I have a feeling - I live
coding
is a live coding competition john mcloon
couldn't do it well i don't know what to
say check if you got the right it was 89
well all right we have the question
number two totals so actually first
place for question number two was John
mcloon I apologize for picking on you so
this this is one of the conditions where
the autograder the the kind of default
autograder did not like you apparently
and yeah I don't know I didn't write it
in second place we got girly-girl sander
from the livestream number 2 or 2 points
and Jose again with 1 and we have Total
Annihilation with 1 so if we tally up
questions 1 through 2 Girly's in first
place followed by John mcloon and then
Hart Wolfie and third all right let's
hear for everybody so far yes
[Music]
all right so are we ready for question
three of the wolfram live coding
championship audience are we ready yeah
all right all right judges release the
hounds
all right this is the nearest flag
problem using the nearest function find
the flag of another country that is most
similar to the flag of Italy return the
flags country as a country entity good
luck everyone
okay third question has just just gone
out yeah but here nearest slide so let's
let's take a look at what our
competitors are doing better one over
here I just put the screen up I mean you
should see it and in just a moment so it
looks like competitor two is already
extracting all the flags of every
country I'm gonna change the screen here
to competitor number two the flag for
the after the livestream to see see it
up there yet live coding the tension is
all right so Jessie looks like someone's
calling the task manager yeah competitor
number two all right looks like they're
back in the game I'm afraid I live
stream can see all right there we go
okay so competitor two is having some
issues but I mean it really looks like
they're on the right track in fact most
of our competitors are using the nearest
function but you know what that's fine
sure so it's kind of special to it it is
kind of a super function because if you
have say a list of numbers you want to
know for that list if I give you another
number what's the nearest number to that
number it's super simple okay but what
if you have say geo positions yeah right
the distance function is different there
well what nearest County
yeah and and here we have images so
nearest actually I believe it probably
uses the image distance function it does
so so by default it uses just the
standard image distance yeah so it's a
distance it's just a way of representing
calculating representing a certain
distance but some sort of distance
between two out of two different images
but the important thing is that it's
consistent so sure it works mean and not
to be a stickler but maybe we should
have specified to use the default I it
says to assume the the default perfect
default options for for everything okay
okay so anyways let's take a look at
another another competitor here come
back to join my friends here the judges
okay so we're on competitor 3 right now
they are actually oh I should have been
looking over here it looks like there is
one second looks like we have yeah we
have a correct answer
perfect oh we've had two correct answers
okay so we're behind a little bit all
right we have to correct submissions
we're waiting on the magic third
like this okay so let's just let's see
what's going on with competitor that -
that looks interesting so they're so
anti devalue so they're getting the
flags of every country in the world as
an entity Association so it's a
key/value data structure where the keys
are our country entities and the values
we will be flag images now I think if I
recall correctly there's a very there's
a subtle subtle quality to this this
question which is there are two flag
properties out looks like they're there
session is frozen right there so there
are actually two flag properties for
country our entities in the Wolfram
language of this flag right there what
it returns is a all right we have three
correct submissions someone's flip gets
the countdown going you'll have one
minute
the colonel one minute everyone well 1
Carla needs to abort his evaluation here
not sure what state what state you are
how many correct solutions we have here
but um anyway said what I was saying
about the flag property there's the flag
property on which competitor 2 seems to
be seems to be using and having some
issues which returns a graphics object
which in the wulfing languages of vector
graphics 30 seconds symbolic
representation of vector graphics while
this this contestant over here
contestant competitor number 3 is using
the flag image properties under review
controversy ensued all right we got 5
seconds 4 3 2 1
pencils down all right let's hear for
question 3 all right go to the judge's
table here let the judges iron things
out yes we noticed some of the answers
are under review so it's kind of
exciting as they review the
but we want them to get their $20 in
that case
yes all right we still have the judges
deliberating but in the meantime I think
we should hear it for our competitors
audience there you know this is harder
than it looks
I'll be honest you got the spotlight on
you they say you were just from my
family just messaged me to say that my
brain is exploding so that's how hard
this is they said that you're causing
members of my own family's brains to
write well I'm different I'm saying that
the competitors are having a harder time
than we're having Yeah right
you know we're up here we have just
water we get to walk around stroke we've
had a few drinks the judges are still
debating the controversy here with the
judges I wonder what's going on might
Bend some of these crazy name changers
who is av Sh Matt he's there too
all right it looks like Mads has changed
his username and middle of disguised by
the person running all right well it
looks like the judges worked it out yes
all right
Mads is now being chastised and
reprimanded yes all right there's our
scores right now everyone looks like
curly again all right so let's hear it
girlie everybody nice job and sander
with to Muhammad B I guess with three a
name changer happen to the name changer
all right and ysh with the points the
first point for why SH well done all
right let's hear it again for the
competitors for question number three
did a great job
[Music]
all right we're live everyone from the
wolfram live coding championship 2019
edition all you fans watching on the
internet the incredible audience we have
here it is time for question 4 alright
question number 4 random walk zero
crossings so let's generate 3000 steps
of a random walk process with
probability 0.5 and count the number of
positive trending zero crossings in the
walk for example if we have minus X 0
and X it's considered a positive
trending zero crossing while positive X
0 minus X is negative trending so if we
go from positive or from negative to
positive we've crossed in a positive
fashion since we're dealing with random
walk let's reset the pseudo-random
number generator with seed random of
1989 to make sure that this is actually
deterministic return an integer already
well on their way they've seeded the
random number generator and they've
created a random function of the random
walk process and over 3000 steps and
they plotted that and now I think
they're ok they're going really fast but
I think that's exactly the right way so
yeah take a look at that I mean they've
got sequence cases which is a excellent
way to approach this of the the data
from yeah those 3000 steps oh very nice
yeah and they're finding a sequence
that's that's where the first element is
got a question mark they did yeah
positive is not ahead but I think but I
think they'll they'll find there
they have no plan till they find they're
cute yeah they're so they're finding
sequences within this list of three
elements for the first one is anything
as long as negative the second one is
zero and the third one is again anything
they are doing except they're reading
your mind interesting see I would have
hit the temporal data with normal with
normal yeah
it has gonna do all kammath I'll come a
minus one yeah I think they're good to
go my goodness if we switch to the
second screen it looks like we have some
similar yep similar prose and I think
they might be on the yet that works it
works as well all right since all you
care about in fact I think the sequence
count would be the most the simplest way
about it but it really doesn't matter we
go every okay one answer here all right
one again all right we have one correct
submission so far keep it up everybody
number two we have to correct
submissions to exhibition okay do you
think this one was too easy some of you
are really flying all right we have
three correct submissions so flip oh all
right we have one minute one minute to
try to get it right to get that gift
card to the basement $20 gift card so
the Wolfram store
oh this is great so Jessie can you tell
us a little bit about where the
questions came from yes I wrote all the
questions for this this competition some
of them are reused from previous
competitions where they were they were
later in alright looks like we have
about 15 seconds that's right and let's
get those submissions in all right three
two one all right submissions are closed
all right so we'll wait on the judges
here so Carlo and were you able to
figure it out were you correct you were
correct okay all right Carlo got a green
submission awesome
no absolutely not
Carlo has claimed the pseudonym Gurley I
you know I just don't quite believe that
[Laughter]
whoever Gurley is I'd take that as a
compliment right so there was some
discussion about whether to use values
whether use normal on this using
sequence well I mean I think all of
those could lead to the correct solution
indeed yes so yes there were you guys
all tried this this was a good one in
terms of some variety of solution
approaches that converged on the same
thing
everyone's favorite function we'll have
to vote on that way I mean this this
question was kind of interesting because
you know we had to use seed random to
give it a deterministic feel yes oh and
we have the scores up there we go
awesome so it looks like first place
with four points is sander let's hear it
for sander everybody John mcloon making
a comeback on this question number two
total annihilation in third place with
two points let's hear it for total
annihilation yeah it is and it looks
like at tnb and cheeseburger both pulled
in one points let's see it for
cheeseburger exactly
[Music]
all right welcome back to the wolfram
live coding championship we're here in
the Wolfram tech conference here in
Champaign Illinois we are ready to start
question number five audience let's hear
it for our coders one more time all
right all right and now the question is
live all right
and the question 5 is the historic Lewis
and Clark expedition of 1804 to 1806
began near st. Louis Missouri and
reached the Pacific coast just southwest
of Astoria Oregon find the shortest
chain of bordering US states that
connect the states of Missouri and
Oregon starting in the former ending in
the latter so the shortest chain
connecting Indiana and Tennessee would
be the list you see on the screen so
Indiana Kentucky Tennessee return a list
of administrative division entities
there's a nice set of hints in the
question good luck everybody
is a good one I like this one okay
question number four sorry question
number five the state chain is out let's
take a look at I think over here yeah so
the second screen right here I think
they're on the right track here they've
got continental US state so US states on
the North American continent the Hawaii
isn't going to fly into into the result
here so that's fine yeah although it
doesn't matter because you were looking
at bordering states and Hawaii doesn't
borders no grain but anyways they're
looking at the yeah the bordering states
property which for a given state entity
and US states are represented as
administrative division entities that's
why and that's why it says it in the the
question is return one that's exactly
yeah hopefully but sure they're okay
they're on I think they're on the right
track here fine sure this path that's a
graph theoretic function and so they've
converted these these bordering states
to the list of bordering states for each
each given state this states that each
state borders they're trying to convert
that into a graph so they can so they
can use the graph theoretic
functionality to find the shortest path
between one point or another that
between one vertex and another so let's
see where hurry Oh they've got it
they've think that that's there that
over there over like 50 percent of yes
they have data they have the data set
and now it's fine shortest path yeah and
I think they are gonna this one there's
gonna yeah just between the two vertices
yeah I think we're gonna have a correct
answer
oh my goodness say there they're just
putting the the arguments in to find
shortest paths let's see if it works now
let me see what the correct answer is
supposed to be they have Missouri
Nebraska u.s. Wyoming and Idaho and
Oregon yes that's correct
yeah so and you know I hate to prejudge
yeah I believe that's the that's the
correct slogan look we have a graphical
oh yeah here on number three
yes I remember yeah I'm number three I
love that we have one correct way Jesse
no one has done one correct during this
trip do caress one yeah I think we have
I think we have modern medicine can you
hear me to prevent that this is good
yeah that's um so yeah there are best
stats well can you hear me okay there we
go
we have to correct submissions all right
I'm loving this so this one is actually
a really interesting solution it is not
the expected answer but they've um so I
have a hunch that Total Annihilation got
it right yeah he's missing and they're
and they're finding the states that it's
not the problem because we're what we're
interested in is the shortest chain not
that that just happens to be underneath
a geodesic nonetheless it's a really
interesting attempt and I believe this
is by host:this solutions is by Jose who
is one of the developers of the
geographic okay this is this is the kind
of stuff that he likes to write
absolutely absolutely
yeah the geodesic because it's
adjacencies and not so it's topological
and not geometric here that we're
looking for right so three correct
submissions so the one-minute countdown
starts now
so Jose solution so we see it in 106
Jose has a one-liner solution to this
problem but he's sure
geodesic distance that's true the
question is it is it connectivity or is
it is it is it is it as a distance it's
very elegant but as we pointed out my
[Music]
imeem that's the thing about these
questions it's really hard to make it
100% ironclad all right all right and
now time is up time is up and actually
you know what let's give a round of
applause to the judges the judges have
been hard at work this entire time
trying to make sure everything's running
smoothly and you know what I think it
has been
come over and talk to Jose because this
we were we were distracted by the by the
topological solutions and then started
to notice little bits of Geo data
showing up and so can you tell us what
the book was the main thought that will
you know yeah if we can get Jose's
solution back up on the screen it's an
interesting so I had to define a way
[Laughter]
that's right that's a really great
solution so the common theme of the
night though is people said the
documentation they just go to the
documentation what to do I don't know
who's here from the documentation group
but how about a round of applause for
the documentation goodness gracious I
mean I can't think of any other language
that has well documented as the Wolfram
language not even close oh my gosh amen
yeah oh so are we in you guys got him
yes that's the sad part is the clever
solution was not correct so regardless
it looks like question five the first
place with four points total
annihilation
all right the competition and in a close
second with three points
Carolee followed by sander and John
mcloon all right let's hear it for them
all right
and let's hear it for Jose
[Music]
all right we're back in snowy Champaign
Illinois is it snowing yet it looked
like it was gonna snow sorry about that
I'm getting some people flipping me off
from the back of the lip at the bullfrog
live coding championship let's go to the
next one
all right we are waiting on question six
perfect all right join across without
and join across so given the following
definition of args re-implement join
across the catches you can't use join
across so for example we see in this
following piece of code that join across
at @rg
is the same as my join across at at args
alright good luck
okay so question six is up joining
across without and join across now I
have to note here that yeah I did
I did write this question and I'm
noticing now that that that args the
whole thing about joining across a dark
so Steve over complication really quick
here is that how would you invite or if
you have to read that out loud and words
and I guess I wanted to encapsulate
those are going to code one variable
that's defined there it makes it look a
little it really it is my joint across
of that this whole question about making
Wolfram language spoken language it's an
interesting question and I think there
are some tricks for doing that and I'm
not sure this is that's not a
particularly interesting case of that um
I think it's more well try some other
piece of code but I'm pretty sure
they're gonna be some tricks for taking
the nested structure of often language
code and mapping it on to the nested
structure that everybody understands
from spoken language and making open
language easy to understand but I don't
yet know what those tricks are Thank You
Steven
I think we're allowed to talk are we
allowed to talk so I think the first key
to cracking this question is to figure
out what join across actually does you
know it joins across yeah so if I had to
guess actually I don't know what it
would it see I'm thinking emerge right
you would you would have egg goes to one
and it goes to to make it egg goes to
the list one two but I think that's
merge I have no idea what joint across
does well you know what I think by now
all of our competitors know what joint
across does because of the documentation
yeah so competitor one and they've got
joint across up just to make sure and
there they started defining their their
my joint across function doesn't look
like it's working yet and we can see at
in 108 the the expected result that's
joint across at at RS what they're
trying to get out of there my joint
across function that never cluster and
working on let's see so so yeah and then
over here on number four also getting
sure number four we're starting to see
yeah and that's a very similar approach
almost exactly saying
there's other Twitter YouTube which
right now is about seniors Twitter
should be yeah so they're gonna try a
group on that like okay like this graph
here yeah the time to
I'm not sure what exactly I'm seeing a
lot of computers would join a
cross-reference page open it's a good
sign yeah competitor 2 they've got they
put an echo in there somewhere that's
good yeah see what zactly what's going
on inside I think they're trying to
match some brackets yeah so there's some
tuples going on I like the again general
strategies we're still waiting on that
first submission to first correct
submission incorrect submissions I
suppose we can we can bring them up and
look at them here so they've got the
results um I probably should not be
showing that but but the the results are
are well well no I can show that because
that's the that's the result yeah that's
already already here
so join across just I guess suppose I
can do it in here define our yes so this
is what we're trying to get these are
these are the the solutions of our oh
we've gotta correct we have one correct
submission okay and so yeah here these
are I think that one's right yeah I
didn't quite get that one um same we've
been seeing I guess some autograder
problems tonight that's not gonna get
them all just because it's a unsolvable
problem all right yeah it is art so um
yeah because the autograder is more
complicated than just looking at the
result it tries to be smart and so you
can't just if you calculate if you like
here if you did joint across at at args
and you got that was that answer you
couldn't just make that your input
evaluate it that's the same thing as the
output because that's not you haven't
solved the problem you've just you
answer the expected answer so yeah it's
trying to be more more smarter than just
comparing outputs um so yeah here we've
got that this one also looks right looks
like they've been looks like there have
been several I want to go over and check
out the judges to see if they noticed
that yeah the answer is supposed to be
this this list of two associations
somehow these yeah this one's got for us
and there's wrong this one returned oh
well yeah they were just today right but
it works so they they all they did they
made the mistake of instead of returning
I believe it it says does it yes his
return return my joint across at at arms
so yeah how long stead of instead of the
well but yeah as long and fortunately
yeah um well the this is correct but
they submitted the wrong thing and by
the way I've noticed that he has now
lodged a protest with the judges
Oh interesting you wanna get you want to
go ask to give to get the inside scoop
so so yeah we were we noticed you had
lodged a protest with the judges what
was the protest over alright we have to
correct submissions again we're waiting
on that third
good
we have three all right we have three
three one minute everyone one minute 60
seconds how'd you do on this you get
this one all right good
all right well oh good that's good
whenever whenever the judges give you
the high sign that's always possible
that's a good that's a little bit of
love from the judges that's good there
was no there was a little bit of a you
know there were some protests mm-hmm but
luckily this is a not a wrestling match
yet all right we got ten seconds
everyone ten nine eight five seconds
four three two one
shut it down gentlemen Oh was last
minute let's hear it for the last minute
good job good job that's 20 bucks at the
last minute
that's a him
all right we'll wait for the judges to
finalize their decision so let's go
ahead and take a look at Jesse screen
that has a correct solution is this just
a hard-coded solution something's not
right here
yes he just got up no we were this was
Jesse and I trying to make a special we
were trying to evaluate something on his
screen and then he got up to go check
something out so that is not a solution
all right so that's so that's the Flip
solution the perfect solution all right
Jesse's a possible to make the text a
little bigger thank you that's the same
there we go
there's one there we go
perfect so while we clear all at the
beginning while we wait for the judges
to update let's soak in what's going on
here a lot of people tried that to get
the two basically set up the left-hand
side find all combinations and then a
good use of select again to select from
those that met that condition join them
all together everything worked
I see so we're selecting all the
elements that have the same key or whose
key points to the same thing same gotcha
gotcha yeah so that's a good solution
yeah it's a clever solution I don't
all right so we got Total Annihilation
throwing some salt saying it's not the
most efficient solution no I think the
least efficient solution is a random
until it's right sure but you know for
the purposes it works yeah all right and
we have the updated board so first place
this time is Timothy V with four points
let's hear for Timothy next is total
annihilation with three Jose with two
degenerate artists one and we have do do
with one and bandit with one and it
looks like we need to deliberate with
the judges here really quick yeah we
have a few protests you see folks this
is a really competitive thing right we
we really want to make sure we get it
all right
I surely is about to flip the judges
table over in a in a rage oh so girly
was the unfortunate recipient of a false
thumbs up oh oh man that's our bad yeah
yeah it's like when that person says
waves hi to that person behind you and
you wave back and sander did everything
get worked out with you yeah okay okay
all right a little controversy it's hard
to avoid it's hard to avoid all right
but regardless I think we should hear
for the competitors clearly they're
passionate about what they're doing
right this is a marathon
[Music]
alright welcome to the Wolfram live
coding championship we're ready for
question number seven the question is is
the audience ready or the coders ready
let's hear it let's hear it all right
I saw Flip earlier head banging his head
so let's hear it flip question number
seven ah parentheses adding so given the
string quote four minus two times three
plus four unquote find all the
parenthetical groupings of exactly two
sub expressions at a time for which the
final expression evaluates to a positive
number return a list of strings that
have been passed through sort yeah we
should note that this is the last
question of the night so if you want to
get that $20 gift card question eights a
tiebreaker
you know why not okay chip hey so this
is this is a this one I think is it
pretty difficult or more difficult than
the others it's a I mean I I just right
off the bat can think a common
combinatorial explosion yeah it's um so
it's a it's a you can you could you can
think of solving it using expression
restructuring like using multi-language
expressions but then you have to keep
everything held and and make sure that
it doesn't escape so my as we see screen
three is doing oh yes screen three
exactly so they've they've they're
carefully holding every every expression
well Wow no idea what that is but yeah
they're inherently whole holding the
results that they're working with um the
solution that I my example solution for
this was actually something different
and I have to say I'm not particularly
pleased with my own solution because I
think it's an elegant I did it entirely
using string manipulation
okay um which yeah I mean actually we
see that screen one yeah they're doing
something like that as well
so but I mean to you know sing the you
know just you're too hard on yourself
okay perhaps I am but yes screen three
we saw them on there they're on the
documentation page I believe yeah for
from groupings which is that's the
that's I believe the the way to solve
this or at least at least one perhaps
most obvious way and let's see who else
I'm not sure if anyone's gotten up got
in groupings yeah well we see screen for
has grouped by typed on their notebook
okay yeah they do although its above so
it might have been for the previous
question we're looking at this screen he
interested not sure if that's that's
very mission I don't see much typing
going on at all and a screen for grabs
just some some thinking pondering the
liberation screen three again I think
they're they're the furthest ahead there
I think they understand the question
let's see if that's is there are two
parts of it there's finding finding the
the groupings but then that they're
doing here I believe it with that final
sell slings yeah it looks like they just
want to find the string that generated
forty down there is that correct or not
understanding the question let's see are
they
yeah I think that's that's wrong here um
but not sure not sure what what they're
trying to do there no I think that's
exactly what they're doing so they're
grouping the integer with the associated
string and they should call maximal by
with last shirt yeah second argument and
that'll that'll grab that tuple yeah
they can throw away the four-day throw
away yeah I see and I should do it good
I like trying to mind-read yeah watching
watching people write code if you've
ever had anyone stand over your shoulder
while you're trying to write code and
how it kind of sucks parts of your brain
out while that happens this is trying to
do it even do it remotely it's just an
incredibly challenge and it's kind of
fun I I'm a big fan of looking at what
people do with the cursor because it
helps it gives you some kind of an idea
about what part of the expression it is
that they're you know that they have
some question about and so you watch
them kind of slide the cursor
looks like number one there's kind of a
speed bump Road Bluffs ya know it's sort
of interesting three out of the four
competitors are using string
manipulation while screen three is
actually is no the screen three is jump
to string Munoz put a two string in
there the input form it's getting a
little clunky yeah it's a little clunky
but you know what that you know yeah
don't care it looks like they're
exposing bugs along the way so this is
interesting so what the the what
essentially people are trying to do I
think is you've got this this expression
this is 4 minus 2 times 3 plus 4 and
then their time good we just left okay
he's left us okay but I
so the parenthetical groupings are just
putting parentheses in arbitrary place
as long as those enclosed exactly two
sub expressions so they're taking out
like with this competitor number three
here there they've on that line that
starts with groupings they've discarded
they've stopped they put aside for the
moment where the plus and the minus and
times are where they the operations are
and they're just trying to form those
groupings and then they have to stick
them back in stick the the operators
back in and and evaluate it and see if
it works
so let's see see which ones admit add
two and then their husband number two
string pulled it back
I mean it looks like they're trying to
do now it's almost their solution yeah
what I have no idea what's what's that
we're still waiting on that first
correction submission oh I see see a lot
of you using string manipulation for
this one that's a certainly a convenient
way to go we have one in the correct
submission they could call it a cheat or
a John mcloon looks flabbergasted over
here John you care to tell us on staring
at the question you know I hear you he's
pre calculated or pre created those
groupings and he's just select that one
select that are positive so it's not if
not a real solution I mean hopefully the
judges will notice right I think they
will okay so where are we saving his so
he's got should the another trick right
a slight development there are no
correct submissions thus far so it was a
bit of a bit of a hiccup a reason one of
the reasons I suppose that I chose
string manipulation and that other
people have chosen to do that to solve
this is that on this Jose here where
he's using direct I went away but using
a direct expression manipulation you
lose the the asterisk as the times
because if by default
yeah it becomes the space times or
whatever whatever that that is the space
that gets interpreted as a times so and
since the result is expected they get
shown in the in the example or that yet
the example for that other string you're
supposed to have those I'm seeing a lot
of grouping subsequences string
expression
a mutation they saw
string insert insert so yeah that's
interesting so they're inserting the
groupings the the parentheses manually
by Chiu just choosing places to put them
in and everybody's very concentrated if
you could do that because again this is
the final question last chance to get on
the board remember if you're on the
board at all you'll get a $20 gift card
to the Wolfram store down in the
basement let's go over the competitive
number two over here they've got a whole
lot of stuff going on I'm not sure if I
can make sense of that but that's not a
bad thing it's just complex see we're
doing some debugging with echo over
there so I think they've in a sense it's
a pretty convenient function really in a
sense they've they've are they do you
think they're re-implementing groupings
I think this person has used a lot of
this selector syntax q maybe whoever's
on the screen syntax Q so a bunch of
those things there I suppose those are
valid groupings but they're not they're
not they're not what the the result is
supposed to look like so I'm not sure if
this this approach is going to work but
never now all right we now officially
have one correct submission number for
here I'm curious what curious what the
correct solution is and it's e they're
gonna add syntax Q there let's see no
we're looking at a number I think we're
still on - I don't remember for who's
defined a function
in instr pair perhaps insert pair which
is yeah that's that that string string
insert except they've they switch to
just working with lists of characters
instead of the abandoned working with
directly with the strings and they're I
think they're trying to might have some
doing things on the wrongs in real quick
how's it going um I have flown the back
what in these Jose's found a bug perfect
you know I feel the the whole room feels
her sentiments right now this seems to
be a tough question so I think I was
saying earlier that I tried to write the
questions at equal difficulty level this
this seems to be the exception I was I
was worried about using this question at
all because it is a little measurably
more complex than the than the others as
we can tell by the time taken to solve
it but I think it's an it's an
interesting problem it's it's it's quite
easy to conceptualize what what what the
expected what you what the question
expects you to do or wants you to do
then going back to the Coulomb tones out
it jeopardy could use this right looks
like everyone's too concentrated to
listen to me that's the way it should be
a good way of putting this and people
are very the approaches are very but you
know a certain amount of variation where
people again are yeah they're going yeah
they're so I think Jose has been three
here has been switching between string
string manipulation and raw Express
manipulation I think he's back - he's on
a swing swung back to the strings which
I think that might it might be that
that's the the right way to do the
strings or lists I suppose because in
theory working with raw expressions make
sense but again the issue of how the
result is supposed to be a string yeah
living in a universe John can we get an
update yeah exactly
are you finished reading the question
there now
all right John's read the question and
he has a plan in a half hour we got it I
think he's got it
yeah and he's just those two expressions
well except there yeah it valuates to a
positive number since that is that it
because he's selecting they're the ones
where yeah what is that
select oh no we're not inside the select
that's inside the sort I know is it I
can't oh okay yeah I wish I could click
in there and get the other see see the
the bracket matching but I'm now he's in
his select and so he's he's he's
generated a bunch of things and now he's
filtering out to have only the ones
where there are four parentheses because
that's those are the I think the yet
because there there's still anyone's
game here well no there it's only
groupings of exactly two sub expressions
at a time but a sub expression can be
itself a parenthetical grouping so
there's three nesting is well okay that
one's nested right there yep but Nia
nesting is allowed so again as I've been
walking around I've been noticing a lot
of string
syntax or numbers you can filter those
out with syntax and humans in the in the
example like parallel example solution
for that five plus six times seven and
on the lower third at the bottom oh that
yeah those have fact they all have six
parentheses so I guess they I guess it
has to have exactly yeah I think it must
have must have them six parentheses all
right so we have a group over here that
claims to have the correct solution so
let's go deliberate with the judges
correct so I will go deliberate with the
judges yeah let's see if we can which I
don't know what their user name is
otherwise I'd bring it up on the from
the judges around here but okay let's go
let's take a look at another one of our
lessons so what's going on over here
with contestant one what are you user
names bend it and who and who else bend
it too oh we're all bandit bandit is
claiming they have it so let's let's see
or why okay brought up I brought up here
this yeah this is the solution that
bandit submitted read the question
carefully
aha
there's there's a sentence a sentence
towards the end you need to read and you
have this thing here take a look at yep
yeah they didn't sort it it's a return
pass through sort it's important to have
that kind of thing in the first place
otherwise it's not specified what order
the results are expected to true and the
other since there are multiple ways if
there are always multiple ways of
solving questions it's possible a
different method might result in a
different natural order so it's
important for these questions to have
that to specify explicitly that returns
out so it looks like we're having some
ambiguity issues as to what are you
sorting with respect to the string or
the value I wouldn't go that far I think
it's an excellent question
okay can I can I talk through this
microphone well anyway so apparently
people think the question is ambiguous
that I guess that part about sort I
think I think that's pretty yes a list
of strings that has been asked through
some sort there's no there's no
ambiguity yeah and it's not if maybe if
it said that have you would think that
the passing is applying to these each
string but no it's a list of strings
that has been passed through sort so I
want to challenge this allegation of
acuity okay let's see what's what's
going on with contestant four here
they've they've got they've they've they
have multiple functions defined to try
to solve this and possible been good
news you got it
it does but we've we made a note the
only way to calm this table down I mean
you've been going for two whole hours
it's 5:00 in the morning for you oh wow
I'll give you a pass here you know it
wouldn't be a wrestling match without it
throw by table instead of sort by
you know it's nice to see about a little
more than half of the competitors have
at least one point it's very nice
right
and I think it's interesting to note the
current state of affairs we have a tie
for second place so depending on how
this question goes there could be a tie
and we would need a tiebreaker
so Total Annihilation and sander it's up
to you
[Music]
so they have
yes we have another contest so ad
possible just based on the name of that
function that sounds like they're
generating these candidates strings so
all of the possible groupings and then
add possible is I would expect it would
be using two expression to evaluate them
but it seems to be doing something more
more complicated than that
so ad possible what is character the
function carrot I know those characters
but the character I don't think that's a
function no it represents this
represents a single yeah but then why is
it why are they calling it within within
with I don't think yeah I'm not sure
what I think they're using this yes I
don't think they're using that right so
got asked again John any updates
it looks my answer looked too simple to
be correct I mean the output is too
simple but I'm about to all right we'll
see that string is just you're trying to
hold that as one of the strings from or
one of the characters from the
expression that you have so the trend
just represented so just using character
just because yeah it could be anything
okay well we have to correct submissions
thank you fresh submissions I'd like to
I suppose we should we should wait to
until we have three to bring up those
and take a look at them but well you
know I'll break that hold on a second
yeah I think the the graters marked them
all is incorrect I just need to check
these so here
okay here's so okay I'm just gonna
switch over to my screen now so here's
one that well came through I don't think
it's the first correct solution but it's
one of them so they've got there they're
the original thing is 4 minus 2 times 3
plus 4 so they've broken that just down
into a list and they're getting the
groupings of 2 which looks like that so
these are you can see those are like if
you treat these as parenthetical
expressions that's these are the all of
the possible things and each of these
does have 6 look I mean excluding the
outer list it has 6 parentheses in it 3
open 3 so now it's this is that's easy
yeah then it's just the matter of
getting putting the operators back in
yeah yeah so the ones that are yeah
where they are above selection right
yeah so they've now how are they I don't
see to expression happening oh ok so
they are not using string manipulation
yeah they are they are oh okay they're
doing it in two steps they're using
expression manipulation to just put the
functions plus you know I'd like to
commend everyone you are concentrating
for a very long time yeah we're still
waiting on that number 3 spot
evaluating that and then finding the
solutions which are these two selecting
of the groupings the ones that that so
audience this is a hard question can we
get a quick round of applause to try to
get the spirit up I know we can do this
I've walked around I've looked at
people's screens and we have a third
correct submission we're gonna start the
one minute timer
and you know what I'm gonna double it
it's gonna be a two-minute timer this
time yeah I'm gonna start it again he's
not very good at computers so I I've
tried to dabble yeah now we're gonna
we're gonna stop this we're gonna go two
minutes we're gonna make it crazy you
know what we're gonna make it two
minutes
two minutes two minutes and four seconds
oddly specific yes but it starts now
yeah whoops no it doesn't yeah it's over
all right it's just one minute thanks
blue thanks thanks flip flip Phillips
everybody yeah Gurley is typing away to
the mellow sounds frankly everybody is
mellow sounds of Wolfram tone C Jessie
over there he knows what the correct
answer is Andre Andre
yeah this is all from Tom yeah that's I
thought this was Wolfram tons all right
I'm gonna start the minute time again
now there is one minute remaining I told
you I'm giving two minutes this time I'm
fairly certain this is who we want
everybody to get a point on this board
it is wool from Tom's perfect I've been
instructed to correct your
[Music]
we got about 30 seconds
Sanders grabbing his head with anguish
it can be frustrating wiping the sweat
from his brow shaking his head
loosen the all right we have 5 seconds 3
2 1 time is up everybody so again I want
to give a big round of applause not only
for this question it was a tough one
we were waiting a while but for the
whole whole competition right our
competitors tried really hard and I
could see the frustration the excitement
all the emotion it's been great so we're
gonna wait on the judges here yeah there
is an opportunity for a tie there is I
was saying if total annihilation and
sander both don't place and John mcloon
and Timothy can't knock them out somehow
Total Annihilation
hits it and Gurley does not sander hits
it yeah it's pretty exciting is it up oh
it's up ladies and gentlemen bandit with
the four points alright
bandit nice team bandit and then
degenerate artist number 30 second place
and three points alright
and then finally ysh in third place with
two points
alright Zed let me guess you
[Applause]
[Music]
hey welcome back it is tie break time at
the live coding championship wolfram
technical so I think first off it looks
like girly has got first place yes but
the question very good job the question
remains who gets second and who gets
third so first I think we should reveal
each other Total Annihilation
stand up wave we have total annihilation
and sander so for the tiebreaker
it will only be these two competing yes
all right
head to head a head to head a head this
has never happened a first this is a
first for the live coding championship
all right all right sander has just
taken a drink of water yeah I need to be
hydrated hydrate up here Carlos Carlos
sit down I got you
Carlos says ask our lunch boy and that
was actually part of the competition so
we're all right he is he is now
hydrating all right house you must
remain hydrated everyone's welcome to
try this on your own but this man this
question is between the two of you and
again I want to hear from the audience
we got a first tiebreaker ever in a live
coding championship big time excitement
it is it's big time excitement I'm
serious here all right what are the odds
yes Ruta someone could probably
calculate it and I think I think Jesse
may be able to reveal the each of they
are both of you guys plugged in so we'll
be able to reveal as you are trying to
solve here so this will be exciting the
whole world is attention the whole world
is watching yes
no pressure a good fair enough yes
yeah yeah yeah yeah just yeah oh we
don't have sander online so it doesn't
matter okay yeah well the whole world
will watch Carla yeah we could plug you
in do you is there is there a spare
sander can use someone else's computer
yeah yeah oh good okay we're gonna plug
sander in great all right this is gonna
be good we'll be able to watch yeah the
audience and be able to tell who's
closer who's further okay well we're
getting an adapter we all must have
dongles yes it's Mac versus PC now
they're both facing neuron I just want
to say that this is not my computer and
so the ergonomics of it or but I am an
employee in Sanders now I see so so you
claim a handicap because this is not
your computer you're not used to the
macros okay I've heard it before I have
the control key heard it before yeah I'm
with you on this okay but he is a good
guy this is all about is this good
versus evil can we pin this in a ways is
which one of you is the heel okay you
are the you are the evil okay does
anyone have a folding chair that he can
now crack across the back of sander
before we get started
all right we're still working to get
Sanders screen streamed so we can watch
them go head-to-head this is gonna be
exciting all right I think we got sander
is now sander is live
you got sander are we good
all right
[Music]
all right it is time for the tiebreaking
question of the live coding championship
here at the Wolfram technology
conference and here we go I Bob let it
go here's the tiebreaker full moons on
Halloween out of the next 100 years 2000
19 through 21 19 find those in which the
moon is in the full moon phase at 11:00
p.m. Eastern Daylight Time GMT minus 4
on Halloween October 31st return a list
of years as integers in ascending order
and again let's hear it for them as
they're coding let's hear it it's a race
I love questions that as you become more
incredulous as you read the question
well you see he's trying to really
disambiguate what's going on this is
drew GMT minus 4 all right we got
cheered crappy sander all right so all
right and we got some cheers for Carlo -
I like it
come on right now
all right so on the big screen right now
jesse is showing us sander right now so
we're inside Sanders mind
and Carlo yeah right okay so it looks
like they're on track looks like they
have the right functions they need to
compose them properly all that
deliberative a waning gibbous now flip I
had a problem with that one okay well no
I was gonna ask you do you know the
difference between a crescent and a
gibbous moon waning and waxing do you
okay okay one's on the way pretty sure
the crescent makes the scene the gibbous
is the inverted
trying to act like I know what I'm
talking about anyway let's not distract
ourselves I'm Carlo and sander all right
we got ya so looking at using the moon
phase function yeah
maybe building up an association here
something and sander and looks like he's
doing something similar he's grouping
him in a list rather than a rule you
know it's the same if you really think
about it I'm loving it and it looks like
he's it might be his submission failure
of his own
[Music]
and integers in ascending order so does
he have them sorted there it's too bad
our little thumbnail down there is
hiding the whether it's correct or
incorrect adds to the suspense there we
go
unfortunately for sander you know it
looks like they're converging in so
let's get one more round of applause
here help them cross the finish line
they're sprinting to that finish line my
goodness they are close we see Carlo has
a different answer it's checking it's
incorrect from the looks of it it looks
it looks right yeah though it's not an
ascending order
oh he's reversed sorting it
[Music]
maybe we can flip back to Seoul wait you
have flipped the Sanders see what's
going on there all right he's got the
GMT negative for Dawn
now they are both they are just it's you
can taste it you only got two yeah you
got those three yeah yeah so some of the
some of the audience participants are
getting similar answers all right now we
have a correct answer yes we have a
correct answer all right so all right so
let's hear for them let's hear for our
two competitors in the tiebreaker in a
minute yeah in a minute in a minute in a
minute we have to announce we have to
make announcements this is pretty
exciting I'm very excited yeah all right
so you're gonna cut it loose it's gonna
happen let's see what's going on here
having some technical difficulty here
some discussion yeah are you ready
oh we're gonna we gonna do let's do you
want to do then or special you want to
put those let's all right all right
we're gonna take the leaderboard how the
tension is everyone hold your breath Oh
Total Annihilation Total Annihilation
but it didn't add up because for some
reason the bonus question
all right congratulations to everybody
not even 1st through 3rd congratulations
to everybody one bar Jesse that is the
best bug to have is yeah
[Music]
hey welcome back to the live coding
championship 2019 and we have a champion
we have a champion and it is time to
give away the top three prizes the rest
of you will give away the prizes will
give your certificates after we close
everything out but let's start a third
point so first let's hear for everybody
one more time
this was long but it was also really fun
there was some really creative solutions
and more importantly I mean it seemed
everybody enjoyed it I think and I mean
at the end of the day it's what it's all
about
indeed so without further ado third
place goes to sander nice job here you
go this is your first this is your first
live coding championship yes it's your
first tech conference - all right
wonderful anything to say well it was
very nice
maybe next year again we'll see yeah
very good all right sander everybody and
in second place he eats it out in the
tiebreaker Total Annihilation should be
total eating very nice you have anything
to say Carlo I am the eternal second he
was second place last year maybe even
two years ago your consistence ways the
bridesmaid but last but not least
certainly not least not least let's you
have a big round of applause for our
first place contestant
barely
[Applause]
so wait yes so first a boring we got an
Amazon echoes on stuff Amazon stuff but
most importantly hold that up in the air
you got up in the air
alright slide coating champion awesome
listen Knight 2019 champ yes alright I
gotta ask what's your advice
yeah be me that's a good advice uh I
mean I had some good you know sort of
competition going here so I beat my boss
so I'm really happy about that so I
think that's what really kept me
motivated and how did you prepare for
this this competition hydrated okay so
pure talent and water talent and waters
alright and the Wolfram documentation
alright alright
well again thank you everybody thank you
to our live streamers for seeing us
through thank you to the competitors
thank you to the audience for being good
sports thank you most importantly thank
you to the judges and the Jessie Jeff
and your video and audio crew who had
seamless transitions throughout the
night and thank you to you thank you to
you and we'll see you all right here
next year within thousand twenty live
coding championship warranty all right
all right that'll do it
[Music]
you